find the total distance traveled by the
particle from time t equals zero to t
equals one
now let's remember they didn't say find
the total displacement they said find
the total distance traveled by the
particle so if something goes to the
right by one and then goes up by one
their distance is two and actually if
then if they go back
if they go back
over here actually let me draw a
straighter line if they then go back
to the original starting point and then
this distance right here would be what
the square root of the square root of
two the displacement would be zero they
got back to where they started but the
distance would be 1 plus 1 plus the
square root of 2. so how do we figure
out the total distance in this scenario
right over here and let me erase this
since it's not relevant to the problem
it's just to remind ourselves we're
talking about distance
well distance is equal to rate times
time or it's equal to speed times time
so in a very small amount of time if you
want to figure out the distance well you
could take your speed which is the
magnitude magnitude of your velocity
function
if you took your speed
if you that's your speed right over
there
and if you multiply it by a little small
change in time that's going to give you
your your of your infinitesimally small
change in distance over that
infinitesimally small change in time
and if you wanted to change your you
want if you want to find the total
distance over a non-infinitesimal change
in time well then you can integrate
and you can integrate those little
changes in time in this case from t
equals 0 to t equals 1. this is going to
be the expression for the total distance
well what is this going to be well this
is going to be equal to the integral
from 0 to 1.
in the last part of the problem we
already have an expression for our speed
our speed we saw was this business right
over here
so it's going to be equal to
the square root
give myself a little bit more space to
work with it's going to be equal to the
square root of
the vol the x component of the velocity
cosine
of t squared squared let me put the
little other parenthesis there
squared
plus the y component of our velocity
squared the rate of change
of y with respect to time squared so
plus
e to the
0.5 t that's the rate of change of y
with respect to time or the y component
of velocity we're going to square that
this is this is our expression for our
speed as a function of time and then you
multiply that times dt and we're going
to integrate all this and this is going
to give us our total this is going to
give us our total distance and lucky for
us we can use our calculator in this
part of the ap exam so let's evaluate
this
and so let me
let me oops let me turn it on and let me
clear out and so we're just going to
evaluate let's go to math
and function integral right over there
that's for evaluating definite integrals
and we want to evaluate the square root
i'll put a an open parenthesis
of i'm going to have a lot of
parentheses here but let's see if we can
do it so the square root of
cosine of and i'm going to use x as my
variable of integration cosine of x
squared
so that's that parentheses i need
another parentheses
squared
plus e to this business squared well
this we already saw before this is this
is the same thing as e
to the t right if we raise something to
the 0.5 t and we raise that to the
second power 2 times 0.5 t is just t so
let me i can do that if i like i could
just type in all of this business if you
like so plus
second
e to the my variable of integration here
is x
e to the x
so close that and then i close
my square root
see i do that right this closes around
the x squared that closes with that yep
okay that looks right and then my
variable of integration is x and i'm
integrating
from 0
to 1 and now let's let the calculator
munch on it a little bit and i get
approximately 1.595
so this is approximately
1.595 the total distance traveled by the
particle time equals zero to t equals
one which is kind of neat that we can do
these things just from you know the
information that they gave us at at the
beginning of the problem